We're hearing from people from
not only all over the country,
but from all over the world. But let's go locally
first or next. Then go to Matt from Boston.
Matt. What's what's going on with you?
Hello? Yeah. Oh, awesome.
Yeah. So I'm calling. I've
been trying to in for a while, so I got several
questions. I think you can go with one that I
wanted to do since I originally started trying
to call in, which was like Bactrian Roger Stone.
Situation where Barr told them to earth kind of
changed the prosecutorial I don't remember the
details of so long ago about commuting a sentence.
I don't know specifically what he did.
But my question is, like several of the
lower level prosecutor has resigned.
Because of his decision, I'm wondering, like,
what good does that do? Because it seems to me
that he can just fill those positions. With
people that are more sycophants that will
actually go along with those things.
All it does is do a headline grab.
For the day, but then in the end,
there's now more significance.
In power that can actually get those things done.
I totally agree with you. This is this is the
Trump phenomenon. By the by the way, out of
curiosity, are you vacuuming or something
right now? Oh, no. I'm in a recent flood, so.
No, you're lie about it. Sounds like very high
level air filtration systems.
Yeah. It's a it's a funky
negative 80 degree freezer.
That way you're you're calling from
negative 80 degrees right now. No, no. There's
a freezer next to me that makes a lot of. Oh,
my God. I was going to say, what are you
wearing if you're in the freezer? Okay.
So, I mean, listen, this is the Trump thing,
right? This is the Foushee thing. In fact,
people say, oh, should Foushee resign in
protest because of what's going on? Well,
then who gets in? I mean, we already saw publicly
Trump replaced Foushee with a neuro radiologist
named Scott Atlast. So this isn't this is a it's
it's a constant question of waying, resigning in
protest. And because you can't take it and you're
you're you're my nerves are frayed and your mental
health is destroyed. Having to work for these
lunatics on the other side, you've got. Well,
if I leave, they replace me with someone crazy.
So am I not better off by being here? And you're
absolutely right to do it to suggest that
they get replaced with even worse people?
Yeah, that's the frustrating thing, to quit.
You played with Bolton. Yeah. Where I could
have sworn he said like, well, you didn't
resign in protest vs. you know, I don't like
Bolton and I think it's a fair point. Yeah. That
doesn't make makes. It's just like you just stuck
between a rock and a hard place. And I'm just
curious what you think is the right thing to do.
Yeah. Yeah, it's very situational. There's no
right answer. But many times it does result
to it to worst people beat being put
in. Thank you so much for the call.
Great to hear from you. Thank you. All right.
We're going to take a quick break. But if you
are holding, don't hang up because we are going
back to the phones strongly and powerfully,
very, very soon. Quick
break. Back right after this.